president Mac corn is well known for his
forthright views but once again being
outspoken has landed him in hot water
this time it's with Bulgaria and Ukraine
so what exactly did he say I prefer to
have people from Guinea or Ivory Coast
who work legally rather than clandestine
networks of Bulgarians and Ukrainians
both countries were incensed enough to
issue formal protests ambassadors were
holding to explain macrons comments
Macross statement is outrageous because
he is a participant in the Normandy
format and should be specially careful
in choosing words about Ukraine and
Ukrainians in Bulgaria and EU country
this was another example of the
east-west divide within the Union French
president macrons statement is just
another demonstration of political
arrogance and cheekiness what's also
puzzling for Bulgarians is the somewhat
muddled reference to illegal immigration
given that it's an EU country and its
citizens have the right to work anywhere
across the Union including in France
excuse me but is macron really able to
talk about Bulgaria does he know the
Bulgarians well enough to talk about
them like this I find such behaviour
towards us totally unacceptable however
it is clear that there are criminal
networks from Bulgaria operating here in
France and this it seems is what Matt
corn has issue with but how do people in
Paris feel about macarons preference for
working migrants it is ridiculous it's a
French president of all people should
make a distinction like this between the
different types of immigration to France
I don't see why it's from a crowd to
decide who has the right to come and who
doesn't immigration whether from Eastern
Europe or the Ivory Coast is all the
same we allow everyone to integrate here
while it's true that I'm not too keen on
macron in this case I think he's right
it is better to verify who's coming in
control our borders and immigration
Matt corn has since his election in 2017
been clear about his views for the
future of the European Union he wants an
EU army closer integration a Renaissance
of the EU project as such but though is
lofty ambitions were once the toast of
Europe it seems his opinions are more
often than not hitting too close to home
and turning allies against him and there
are warnings that his plans will be
difficult to achieve without friends
Charlotte dumansky RT Paris
you